hey guys welcome to my new video in this
video I'm going to show to make this
animation with using After Effects let's
get
[Music]
started so guys welcome back and first
of want select this background layer and
log then let's create new background
solid layer add the name background one
and click okay move to behind here and
go to F press search f f select F let's
use for background one and go to color
Cube change to White click okay and also
Lo layer then select these character
elements for make comp session select
Body Hit And I white I ball and I Brown
let's see okay let's right Mouse pre
Compass add name
character and click okay and let's hide
come session select is doctors let's
hide layers and select Mouse also hide
layer and backround shape hide layer so
in this time let's go to shape layers
let's hold this icon and let's create
new ellipse tool let's let enable here
tiation save hold shift make one ellipse
cation tool go to F let's click F and
select nor for close inside color click
okay go to stroke withd change stroke
withd
20 and stroke color let's try change
color blue like this or
purple Okay click okay and for Tor Point
center hold control double click Pan
behind icon cation tool and in this time
let's go to window open align click this
icon and this icon for move the object
to
Center okay so change name search
one and select this search one let's
press P move the down make new personing
Q frame go to T Q frames for shortcut
you can use hold shift press page down
in keyboard let's move up go to again 10
Q frames move to
down like
this go to T frames again move up and
again move to down and again move up and
go to click align for move to Center
object so select CH frames make eases
let's
see okay we have problem with ch frames
let's select all chy frames right Mouse
go to chy frame interpetation change
Auto baser to linear click okay let's
say
again okay that's good so let's select
the SE one layer go to add and let's use
trim pads and open here let's go to
first second change and
0% and make in Q frame go to here change
100 100% select Q frames make eases or
click F9 let's
see nice select Q frames go to graph and
select this graph make smooth like
this okay back to CH frames and select
the last CH frame move to
left okay so right now I want to make
smooth line for this let's open contents
one and stroke one change butt cup to
round cup for smooth shape layer and
let's preview
animation okay I like it so select the S
press p and select first s frames go to
graph and let's Zoom to graph select
this graph and move to left and this
moved right for filing
animation okay I like it
so back to CH frames so let's go to
again shape layers and let's create
random rectangle tool and let's Zoom to
here make new rectangle tool and click
selection tool open rectangle and
rectangle P one change redness for
smooth and change
size okay change roughness like
this and click this size icon for make
circle line and click this second for
move to object to
Center okay nice and right now let's go
to here let's first select the shape
layer change name search to and press s
Mak get Q frame change scale zero and go
to 10 Q frames change
120 go to 10 Q frames change 95 go to
again 10 Q frames change
100% let's
see okay so select CH frames make
eases and let's move to
right okay let's move right little
bit select these Q frames hold out move
to
left
okay so right now let's open inside and
contents rectangle one rectangle P
one and right now let's make size Q
frame and rodness Q frame go to here and
change
size and rodness like
this select qy frames make EAS go to
graor select this graph make
smooth let's see
here okay back to Q frame select last sh
frames move to
right okay so let's select this sege one
select last sh frame and move to
right okay so select this last G move to
right
okay let's select key frames go to
grapher and let's make smooth
graph select work
area okay let's make smooth like
this and back to Q frames select last Q
frame and move to
[Music]
more
okay that's good so in this time let's
go to pen tool and let's make line like
this clation tool and open inside
contents shape one and stroke one change
run cup for smooth layer and go to pain
tool select is point moved up
for chain
[Music]
size okay let's move to right here here
and open path one let's go to here make
New Path G frame go to back and select
this P one change like
[Music]
this let's
see okay a AQ frames make eases and
right now let's select the shape layer
change name
search line move to behind search two
and link to search
[Music]
one let's see here move to
left okay not
bad so select the sech one go to here
and move to L
bit nice and select this search
line and go to pen behind move Anor
Point here clation
tool and let's Press air open Rotation
make rotation key frame chain rotation
like this and go to here change Zero
let's change a little bit like this for
bones animation go to here change again
and
here and zero select ke frames make
EAS okay select these ke frames hold alt
move to
right okay so select this first key
frame and let's press you for C active
key frame select this PA layer and let's
open inside select this P one
change like
[Music]
this okay nice so press U again CQ
frames and let's move to right this key
frames okay that's good so in this time
let's close key frame settings and go to
text let's write here online
doctor
clation tool move to here and go to
color let's select this ey dropper
select this color click selection
tool and go to window open animation com
three and open here starter presets and
text animated characters let's select
animation
here okay let's click in and close
conversation let's move to WR this
text let's see full
animation nice not bad so in this time
select his Mouse and enable layer move
to up and move to
down move to right this
layer and press P make new person Q
frame go to F ke frames and move the up
here for Mouse click
animation okay select key frames make
easies and select last key frame move to
right okay go to graphtor select this
graph make
[Music]
smoo and back to Q frames go to here
change graph like this
and select these lines for change
[Music]
curves and let's hold shape Press air
open Rotation make rotation Q frame and
chain rotation like this and go to
here change rotation and go to next sh
frame change
again and let's move to
here select rotation CH frames make
eases
[Music]
okay so go to here and let's hold Shi
press s open scale make SK Q frame and
go to 6 Q frame let's click time
duration we right here plus 6 for go to
six key frames click okay change scale
95 or
85 go to six key frame 1 2 3 4 5 6 for
go to frame by frame key frames you can
use press page down and change 100 scale
select Q frames make
eases let's say
again okay select skety frames move to
left and go to here let's make new
rotation Q frame and go to here change
rotation and next q frame change like
this
[Music]
okay select last G frames hold alt move
right for more slow
animation nice and let's make new
passing Q frame go to some Q
frames
and let's move to right like
this select last she frame move to right
go to graor and make graph
smooth
okay back to two frames and right now
change rotation like
[Music]
this and move to down little
bit let's make this line smooth go to to
pen tool hold this icon go to convert
vertic tool and go to here hold this
point for make smooth and move it down
like this cation tool mve it
[Music]
down okay
nice so in this time select this search
one and right now press s Mak skate key
frame go to six key frames
chain scale 8 and go to six Q frames
again change 100% SEL Q frames make
eases What's the
timing okay move to WR these Q
frames
nice so let's see timing let's select
this Mouse layer and move to left
I want to Dynamic
animation let's move to left
more okay select the SK frames move to
the
left move to right little
[Music]
bit okay so select is mouse and press p
let's move to right
here nice so in this time let's create
new n object and hold control double
click P behind icon for move Tor Point
Center cation tool let's select this
online doctor and search tool search one
select this n object move to
right and after Mouse click animation
press p and let's see let's make new
passing qy frame go to some qy frames
and move
up select qy frames make
[Music]
eases okay select these CH frames go to
graphtor let's make smooth
graph back to Q frame select last Q
frame move to
[Music]
right
okay let's move to left this n
object okay that's good so in this time
select These doctor layers let's enable
let's right Mouse new n object and hold
control double click P behind clation
tool change name
doctors and select is Doctor 4 3 2 1
link to doctor layer and select the new
object press s change
scale and move to
here okay and let's press P move it
down and make new passing Q frame go to
here move
up select key frames make easy
and go to graor select this graph make
smooth
graph okay back to CH frame select last
CH frame move to right and let's see
timing okay nice so let's back to
background one and unlock go to color
change to
White and click
okay okay and let's select these shape
layer colors go to stroke we and change
color to
Blue and also select this text go to a
dropper select this
color
Okay so let's select this mouse and
press
U and in this time let's move to left
for click
here and select CH frame move to right
let's select work area let's
animation okay go to
graph and select this graph move to
right okay back to Q
frames and right now chain
rotation
also select this move it
down and go to this icon make
smooth clation tool and move to down and
change rotation like
this and go to next viy frame and chain
rotation like this for click
animation
okay so again let's make mouse click
animation select the scales copy and go
to here contrl V for
past and select these rotations copy and
go to here contrl
[Music]
V okay let's move the up little bit
up and rotation
[Music]
change select skate G frames move to
left select these less rotation CH
frames
delete also can delete all rotation CH
here and right now let's change rotation
a little bit like this and go to next q
frame change
back okay so let's make new personing Q
frame and go to some Q frames move it
down and go to
Middle let's move to left go to again
this tool make smooth line
clation
tool and let's
see change rotation like
[Music]
this okay that's all let's
see
nice so in this time select this layer
and press
s in this time make SK qy frame go to
six qy frames click here right plus six
click okay and change
80 go to again six key
frames change
110 and go to six CH frames again change
95 again go to three CH frames change
100% say Q frames make
eases okay say Q Fram hold alt move to
right
nice and in this time let's make
doctor's null
object and make new ping Q frame go to
some Q frames and move to
left say key frames go to graphtor make
graph smooth I want to make fake camera
animation okay and select CH frame move
to
[Music]
left back to CH
frames okay so right now let's enable
character C session enable here
and move up and link to doctor's C
session move to write this C
session okay and select this C session
move to
Center and select this background
shape let's
enable also link
to Dr
lion
okay not bad and let's select these
background layer and after Mouse click
animation press T open opacity make
opacity key frame and go to some qy
frames change 0% select Q frames make
eases select last sh frame move to right
let's see
here
[Music]
okay select two frames go to graor and
select this graph let's make gra like
this okay that's
good and select is character let's put
Center okay let's open come session
select this body and go to pen behind
move tanker point
down clation
to and select this here link to body
select this ey white eyeball and eyebr
link to here select here to go to
solo and go to pen behind move Tor Point
down clation tool and UNS
solo and right now select this body
Press air and make rotation key frame
chain
rotation always change like
this change 50 and go to thanq frames
change minus
20 or minus 10 go to 10q frames change
five again 10q frames change minus 2.
5 go to TQ frame change one and TQ frame
change Zero s rotation key frames make
eases let's see
here
move to left little bit or
right okay back to Q frames and let's
hold Shi press P make no pressing Q
frame move to
down and go to here move to
up and go to next ke frame move to down
again and here moveed
up make your frames
EAS
okay back to CH frames let's see here
again nice I like
it so back to Q frames and select this
hit Press air and make new rotation Q
frame chain rotation go to
here and let's put here like this and
chain
rotation and go to here change
three and next VI frame change Zero
say Q frames make
EAS okay so go to here and make new
rotation key frame go to 10 key frames
again hold shift press page down in
keyboard chain
rotation and go to here make new paring
qy frame go to T qy frames change
rotation like this and go to here make
new rotation go to t you frame change
Zero and four bones animation hold shift
press P make new passing CH frame go to
middle and move to down go to next ke
frame say first Q frame copy pass say Q
frames make eases and copy three passing
Q frames go to here contrl V and here
contrl V Let's
see
nice and in this time select is eye
white control defa duplicate select
eyeball move the inside to White layers
and click too switch mode go to non
select Alpha m iy 2 and right now I can
move eyeball inside ey white layers so
in this time go to here press P make new
passing key frame go to two CH frames
one two and let's move to
left select CH frames move to
here nice and make new personing CH
frame go to two CH frame frames move it
down and go to next CH frame make new
passing CH frame go to two CH frames
move to right these eyeballs for look
right and here make new passing CH frame
go to two CH frames move
up and here make new passing Q frame go
to two Q frames and save for G frame
copy pass so let's add I blink animation
set this I I White 2 Link to I white
select I white press s and click this
icon make skate frame go to 3 frames 1 2
3 change scale five go to three Q frames
again 1 2 3 change 100% say Q frames
make eases and move to here this is very
Dynamic and realistic ey blink for when
I white blinking and Eyeball CH frames
and made together let's see
nice this very realistic so select the
SK frames copy go to here contrl
V and here contrl V and here and here
let's
[Music]
see nice so let's delete these G
frames let's say
again okay this more realistic
right so let's back to main compation
let's see
here nice and let's change time duration
of this composition go to composition
and composition settings or contrl K and
change
duration 20 second click okay and select
is on let's unlock background and change
duration and background shape change
duration
and
[Music]
this okay nice and let's press in for
select work area select this full cation
and right Mouse select work
area Okay Noto
bad so guys thank you for watching my
video and don't forget to subscribe
Channel like video and please follow me
on Instagram good luck
[Music]
back